&gt;&gt; So, Susan, you say savory uses MSG. Can you describe this for us please?
&gt;&gt; That's a great question Lauren, I'm glad you asked. This flavor is actually
called Umami, which means pleasant savory taste. You'll find this Umami taste
in things such as aged meats and cheeses. It's a very difficult flavor to
describe, but it's also found in MSG, or monosodium glutamate, which is a
flavoring. So, savory is really a combined sense of both MSG as well as the
perceived savory odors by your nose.
&gt;&gt; Interesting. So, what's expected of our sensthletes after they're presented
with this sample?
&gt;&gt; Well, our senseletes will be presented with five samples, and each of these
will have a very light version of the flavor. Then, they'll have to correspond
and taste each one and correctly identify the basic favor.
&gt;&gt; Now, do we have a projected winner for this event?
&gt;&gt; Well, Lauren. I'm not sure what the stats are for these senseletes. So, we'll
just have to wait and see.
&gt;&gt; Actually, Susan. If you don't mind, I can interject here. I was speaking to a
senselete earlier, Alex, who I suspect may win.
&gt;&gt; Why is that?
&gt;&gt; Lauren, stick out your tongue.
&gt;&gt; Like this?
&gt;&gt; Exactly. Now, do you want to feel the surface for me?
&gt;&gt; Mm-hmm.
&gt;&gt; Can you feel tiny little bumps?
&gt;&gt; Yeah.
&gt;&gt; Now, those bumps are actually clusters of taste buds. And we call these
clusters papilla.
&gt;&gt; Huh. That's interesting.
&gt;&gt; It is. You can actually stick your tongue back inside now, yeah. So, anyways,
humans, on average, have about 10,000 taste buds. Alex, with 10,000 plus
another extra thousand, 11,000 taste buds, just may take home the golden brain
today.
&gt;&gt; That's interesting, Andy. Well, I'm actually getting word that our senseletes
are ready to begin. So, back to you Susan, with coverage of the event.